koné
c'est ce radar locke vous vous êtes
connue non sur quoi alors sur capri
c'est fini
non je crois dans la ronde des étés les
souvenirs précis s'accroche à une mêlée
vie à titre de livre les tubes l'un des
premiers tubes français capri c'est fini
un million de disques vendus en
littérature les éditeurs négliger le
marché des vacances
et puis paru en juin 68 où tu porteras
mon oeil je rends succès depuis maison
de disques des éditeurs s'affrontent sur
les plages pour un investissement faible
cent mille francs environ
les gars atteignent plusieurs millions
un nom est synonyme de succès local
quand on veut faire à tizi ouzou ont
fait appel à lui paroles de pierre
delanoë
et pourtant
des tests j'exècre abomine j'abhorre je
vais ce mode le tube que je trouve
stupide écrire d'une façon simple
l'une des premières astuces pour faire
un succès pour mieux comprendre la
naissance d'un tube
nous allons tenter de remonter
l'histoire de celui de l'année dernière
l'été indien de joe dassin d'abord la
rencontre des saints avait déjà
enregistré ces gens sont rejetés son
directeur artistique se rend à londres
pour une séance de travail et tout d'un
coup ils sont mis à parler d'un disque
italien qui s'appelle fric à tout le
monde en parlait il avait écouté la
semaine précédente et quelqu'un
demandait en vain entendent et ils ont
passé ce disque était que j'ai entendu
j'ai un coup parce que chaque fois que
chaque fois que je tombe sur un disque
comme ça ce qu'elles étaient et ce
qu'ils font quelque chose c'est qu'ils
me font r après le chef l'adaptation
pierre delanoë transforme en beau jour
la vente irda noir ont une histoire
d'amour pendant l'été indien dassin
enregistrant l'opération séduction des
antennes de radio et de télévision
commencent pour lens ira cube tout un
bataillon d'attachée de presse de maison
de disques intervient la mode des
enveloppes adressées aux programmateurs
apparaît-il disparu mais reste les
cadeaux d'entreprise les billets d'avion
gratuits toute une série de moyens
subtils que faire face et une chanson
sur les ondes
et puis l'on avance souvent au seuil de
l'été une intrigue un désespoir amoureux
pour le chanteur pierre delanoë n'est
toujours pas d'accord y'a rien à dire
sur les senteurs et chanteur il chante
il faut les allez les voir sur des
scènes mais les gens qui font des
chansons ils font des chansons et puis
comment il vous fait cette chanson
pourquoi etc
bah ça me regarde personne que vous en
vivez vous de tout ce battage
publicitaire du tout quoi tu peux être
publicitaire - janvier
écouter cette chanson quelques accords
un air de danse une histoire d'amour la
même équipe collègue joe dassin essaie
de renouveler le succès de l'été indien
je lançais le sub de l'année 76,1
millions de disques vendus à 10 francs
45 tours
cela fait 10 millions de chiffre
d'affaires 33% inventa le reste pour la
majeure partie retourne à l'équipe du
disque et pourtant personne affirme
avoir gagné de l'argent après le succès
de l'été indien
la pub ne rapporte pas celui rapporte
c'est une carrière à qui me rapporte la
battue me rapporte aux auteurs de la
chanson oui bien sûr higuain puis sur
une chanson qui marche que sur une
chanson qui marche pas ça il faudrait
que vous demandez à pallavicini qui a
fait la chanson ce qui sait ce que ça
lui a apporté mais dites moi je vais pas
vous de nous poser que des questions
chose pour gagner mais ça paraît assez
bizarre mais ils étaient indiens ne m'a
pas apporté de plus que les autres les
autres titres les autres tubes que je
fais des raisons techniques que ne
comprendraient pas et que les
spectateurs ne comprends pas parce que
je suis un contrat qui fait que c'est un
rapport
ça rapporte à l'artiste à porter
sa chance en
à chacun
tous dans le disque se renvoient la
balle
personne n'a vous faire un tube pour de
l'argent c'est dans la littérature nous
avons trouvé le premier auteur qui joue
cartes sur table celui d'un des grands
succès l'été le break dans le cas précis
du grec oui j'écris ça pour gagner de
l'argent parce que j'avais écrit des
pièces de théâtre pendant quatre cinq
ans quand j'ai voulu laisser un joueur
m'a dit c'est trop intellectuel pour
gagner de l'argent
la plupart des écrivains d'été ont tracé
un portrait robot du héros qui fait
rêver les foules
alanguie sur les plages il connaît la
famille kennedy la mafia le vatican
lehmann k les arabes et les dollars le
glisse entre les doigts
mais les auteurs doivent aussi être vu
sur des affiches à la télévision dans
les librairies et même parfois braver la
poussière et la chaleur ont dit qu'à
sous leur niveau même si l'on désire
simplement faire connaître un organisme
officiel
il faut se plier à toutes ces
contraintes
voilà
si le président est ce que vous comptez
faire un tube c'est parce que nous
recherchons nous cherchons à faire
connaître notre maison alors tant mieux
si ça devient un peu on espère toujours
faire jusqu alors promis qu'un passé
dans big three américains et bon sens de
la marche est décidément personne ne
peut arrêter l'inspecteur borniche
lorsqu'il se trouve devant une caméra
plus en profite même pour placer ces
trois derniers libre car il faut vendre
et vendre encore depuis quelques années
les éditeurs ont trouvé un nouvel atout
pour attirer ceux qui disent peu mais
restent sensibles un emballage bien
ficelé le graphisme de la couverture
ce type comme une affiche de cinéma qui
attire le regard des gens dans la rue
sur quelque chose qui existe
le tube faire un tube il ya souvent une
nuance péjorative de ses expressions
à tort car à sa solitude depuis des
années et les rengaines des plages ont
souvent quelques chars
simplement il faut avoir du courage pour
affirmer je fais un tube pour de
l'argent et ne pas avoir en outre le
traverser l'été entre un flacon de rambo
solaire et une citronnade glacé